500 وسبع بلدات في اوكرانيا دون كهرباء
وفقا يفكيني مين النائب الاول لوزير
الداخليه الاوكراني فان الاستهداف الروسيه
المتواصله لمحطات الطاقه جعل من طاقه
كخاركيز في صداره المناطق المتضرره وان
112 قريه فيها باتت معزوله تليها من فقتا
دونيتك وخرسون حيث تضررت اكثر من 90 قريه
فضلا عن اثتين و80 قريه في نيكولايف و76
تتواصلوا دعوات الحكوميه للصمود امام شتاء
تتسارع خطواته بدا القصف الروسي المنتظم
للبنيه التحتيه الحيويه في اوكرانيا منذ
العاشر من اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي بعد
يومين من قصف جسر القرم وبالتالي تعطي
موسكو الحق لنفسها في استهداف البنا
التحتيه الاوكرانيه
ابرز محطات الطاقه المتضرره هي زابوروجيا
التي تتبادل اوكرانيا وروسيا الاتهامات
باستهدافها وقالت الامم المتحده في ال23
من نوفمبر الماضي ان محطه دار نيتسكا
الحراريه للطاقه في كييف تعرضت للقصف ما
حرم منطقه تكييف باكملها من الكهرباء وبقي
ما يقرب من ثلاثه ملايين انسان في العاصمه
دون مياه هنغاريا كما تعرضت محطه توليد
الكهرباء لدزهند منطقه القصف ودمرت
الضربات الروسيه البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
كريم شوك والبيف واديسا
كانت كيف تستهدف رفع حصه الطاقه النظيفه
الى 25 في المئه بحلول عام 2030 لكنها
وعلى وقع الضربات الروسيه اعلنت فقد نحو
90% من منطقه الرياح و 50% من الطاقه
الشمسيه وكان رئيس مجلس الدومه الروسي
فييتش سلاف فولدين قد اعلن في اكتوبر
الماضي تضرر اكثر من 70 منشاه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا الامر الذي افقد البلاد نصف
الطاقه المولده